you're one word to describe this season
ah
one word latter one this is happy hour
and carried uber is back welcome back
for more punishment thank you
I'm super excited thanks for having me
all right all right
why come back because sometimes you kind
of things like is there something wrong
with you were like you mentally ill I
think in the end I feel like yeah I'm
not done with this there's carries but
how would you say season two other than
there's some new cast members how a
season two different than season one
with the two new cast members I think
you've to find a new who's the alpha dog
you know what do you get when you add
more to the pack who is more the more
[ __ ] in the past I'm not entirely
sure I'd love to say it's me but I don't
think so I'm trying to you know not get
killed is there any fear of getting
killed the sheriff
I mean getting killed in season why you
threaten someone's life the word kill
what I said kill means something
different than what you're thinking so
threatened be going in to fulfill me is
there anything you did differently than
you did in season one I think I just
mentally prepared myself better like I
know what's going on right can handle it
do you think you handled it yeah I do I
handle it better than I did last year
okay
I mean which isn't paying you spend time
with people when you either realize we
love him or hate him
I mean and definitely there's a point
where I'm fighting with people that I
never thought I would would argue about
I'm starting to get like pissed I want
to talk about some of the footage
routine in the trailer Leon breaks a
glass very close to you and yells we
will never be friends
what leads us to that moment um a lot a
lot of different things that I don't I
don't even know that I know everything
that happened and I think you can stay
to my face I was just like I was done I
was like oh come on turn off oh I was
like glazed over and literally sitting
there like in the first episode it looks
like we are headed in a positive
direction and then it kind of took I go
this way
take a turn okay I think that I want a
want to be your friend
it's gonna take a minute boo like I'm
not gonna just like run on you know
right run on over and be like okay you
know so yeah take some time but I
definitely putting forth the effort but
so wait and see what happens
does the effort pay off and are we going
to see you guys get close at any point
during yeah okay there's a little bit of
bopping there cool brother bonding yeah
the question is does it stick you told
Stephanie that I was up to my old ways
by me
raineesha did you enjoy this season more
less um I think I enjoyed it more I
definitely have a lot of ups and downs
this season though and I I mean like it
depended on the the day you caught me
like what when we go back from one of
our trips I that was what you saw with
with me and doing the thing at me I mean
that was like that day in particular was
just like a nightmare so I think for me
it was just a lot of highs a lot of lows
it's life it's life well congratulations
just you know Cheers
you survived filming no I survived
watching it back
[Music]